[Norvig] Okay, so we're going great and we're almost done.
We just need to implement kind and 2 pair.
So let's write some tests first, as usual.
Again, I'll do the tests for you.
So what I've added here is one more card or one more hand to deal with--
2 pairs, a pair of 5s and 9s with a 6 left over--
and then I pulled out the ranks of 4 of a kind ranks and 2 pair ranks
by calling card_ranks,
and then I made these assertions.
So is there a 4 of a kind in the 4 of a kind ranks? Yes, there is.
And in fact, it's a 9, those four 9s.
Is there a 3 of a kind there? No, there's not.
We're asking for exactly 3, not at least 3,
and so there's 4 but there's not 3.
Is there a 2 of a kind there? No.
Is there 1 of a kind? Yes, there is. There's four 9s and there's one 7.
So 1 of a kind in 4 of a kind ranks is yes, there is. There's a 7.
And then in terms of 2 pair, does the 4 of a kind have 2 pair?
No, it doesn't, so we return None.
And does the 2 pair have 2 pair? Yes, it does, a 9 and a 5.
I'm going to ask you to write the kind function, which takes the n of a kind you're looking for,
the list of ranks, and it returns the rank that that hand has exactly n of if there is one
and returns None otherwise.
And it should go through the ranks in left to right order
and find the first one that corresponds to n of a kind.